[Applause]
greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happening now is brought to you
by my personal favorite on it for your
sports supplements from the the new whey
protein the Dolce that Mexican chocolate
[ __ ] delicious to the alpha brain to
the shroom tech on it is number two to
nobody you understand me then number one
they don't [ __ ] around go to anicon
right now press in charge
BAM and get 10% off your first order
delivered right the house that's how we
roll number two you know me dawg I'm no
[ __ ] any Bravo but I try to do what I
do twice a week just to keep the blood
flowing I'm an old man people cutting on
my [ __ ] G and closed guard listen if
you want a tough solid gear you're a big
guy
Fuji all the way baby from the
all-purpose game to their competition
G's in my world it's Fuji all the way go
to Fuji sports right now we just want
that time right now and press ENTER CH
boom and get 10% off again whatever ghee
the super ito the cyclone point to the
the psycho sei que 0.2 they redid it or
just a regular elevator it's a beautiful
like ghee on hot day is they'll rock
your world go to Fuji sports.com right
now press in church bad get 10% off your
order kick this [ __ ] melee are
you [ __ ] nuts or what old-school def
leppard still on the [ __ ] road doing
that thing I got the name of the song is
woman it's Rob states terry alban and
the reason why i opened up but is
because my main woman is in the [ __ ]
studio I love Quigley and this guy's
quill I'd miss you too I was worried
about you you ever hook up with the guy
in Charlotte the guy in Charlotte yeah
we talked about setting some dates up
okay
use your great Club Charlotte that's
don't ya about doing a few like doing a
run and hitting a few can
he's got South Carolina a couple days
he's so fun good yeah I love it out they
wanted to get you out there how are you
I missed you man was it weird I was
saying it was only like a few weeks I
didn't see you but it felt like forever
I just talked to you so much night I
take for granted that I bump into you
like once or twice a week so it felt it
was weird I was like it was like you're
like one of my closest friends like I
realized that when I wasn't seeing you I
was like oh I need like a hug from Joey
yeah no it's yeah listen the comedy game
doesn't give you a lot of friends like
not yeah I want the cactus with Arion oh
that's cool
wait what's cactus that a restaurant
called plays oh nice you Simone showed
up I go see it is the kitchen to the
gods
that's a David badmouthing cactus no you
weren't there wrong [ __ ] cactus
really yeah cuz this three of them
there's one of Beverly up there in the
valley
there's one on Moorpark and Tujunga and
then there's one on North vine oh
they're all valid no line in Hollywood
yeah the hotel so sometimes if you're
coming home from the store just hook a
[ __ ] right on vine and they're open
it's cash only I have to try it like
mighty angle isn't that name a bunch of
cats live in that neighborhood they know
about so yeah day we were at coffee and
Steve Simone was complaining about
[ __ ] no more parking woman more
parking Woodman so today and when he
came over Ari I go what do you want to
eat and he goes only the Mexican I go I
only go to cactus or like if it's family
I'd take him to the best is right up the
corner him he can't get a table what's
that salsa and beer oh yeah I've never
been if I'm going out to eat Mexican
mamas awesome beers I [ __ ] that
restaurant and you know yeah Dave lien
and i wham coffee talking about the
podcast and Stallone and I'm like I feel
like pastrami how you get three ounces
of pastrami with two pieces of bread and
it's like six way watching point so
anyway watching
with mustard with the coleslaw it's not
bad it's like three points for coleslaw
only wait two pieces of bread and still
under six it's what you ask the Rye
bread is too how many do you get in a
day 39 oh wow I can't believe it's that
low so two prices of bread is four
points and 3 ounces of pastrami lean is
like four points something [ __ ]
outrageous so I went to this pastrami
place it was god-awful it was God off on
its own it's always been 50/50 I can't
why do I go there for convenience the
guy's is a genetic Ambler but his wife
is really sweet
she's 60 she's got the ass of a 30 year
old yeah she's Jewish too and she's
[ __ ] buying it really well those
dark-skinned Jews one of those [ __ ]
Sephardic Jews she's [ __ ] banging
she's got a past I'm a thirty year old
really and I wanted midea the month the
wife wasn't there but the food was
horrendous
it was just god-awful so there's a place
downtown if you ever want real [ __ ]
pastrami it's all langurs do I sell dude
do I strike you as someone that's
looking for pastrami but really I was
gonna say I don't think I've ever in my
life been like I could really go for on
but they took an old it's like be like
Cantor's yeah okay it's can't this only
high-level with a line you get there at
20 to 12
sorry Charlie it's a 30-minute wait done
see you gotta go out 11:15 when the
pastrami comes out of the oven
you gotta get there at 5:00 after 11:00
and wait to ten minutes like I sold you
just have a cup of rice yeah a couple
chicken and rice is three points you
know you don't die I love you I love you
on the point system so I love it it's so
great you look it's working like nah I
gained weight because something's going
on that's why I went to the doctor fake
or something may right did I don't you
know what what I couldn't you're still
so thin gonna [ __ ] get down at 265
how much weight did you gain back a
couple of three pounds that's it now
that I lost one point six so it's like
I'm up wanted to have something digest
and something I'm slipping with
something it could be the expired
edibles no it's the green house I go to
a natural fruit place to green house
yeah
it's delicious and it's really healthy
but that stuff blended kills you what do
you mean love smoothies like I'm sorry
why too many carbs too many points what
do you mean it's hard to count blended
and fruit eaten raw is Tamara Fletcher
so fruit eaten raw you could eat it all
day long and not gain an ounce but fruit
blended becomes something else
oh you know what so when you put banana
blueberries and acai blend it up it
becomes sugar sugar yeah yeah you put
the fruit and the granola on top even
though it's super light granola granola
is a lot of points it's like eight
points for a [ __ ] it's heavy it's heavy
so and I'm a big [ __ ] kombucha dude
oh you love kombucha that's a lot of
sugar that's a lot of sugar so it says
eight ounces is two points but I drink
sixteen ounces yeah it's a lot of people
your belly good he's a lot of edibles
you should explain that you should just
do apple cider vinegar instead like that
I do it I do it it's supposed to help
keep I'm like really into it's weird I'm
really into like food and Dietetics I
almost major well I do the green [ __ ]
every every time I go to the green house
I order the [ __ ] tell me yeah the
whole thing it's like it they got some
great juices there they really do cuz
when I buy the juices I actually look to
see how many because sometimes there's
one Apple sometimes there's a half Apple
like right but you know what not to do
like an ad for them but I used to be
obsessed with making smoothies and I
tried all the different blenders the
nutribullet the Vitamix for real is
amazing baby it's amazing because you
can put a whole Apple in it I eat the
core the seeds when it's blended up I
see you can't even tell you can't tell
you're getting I had I sound like I'm
doing an ad for them you get all chance
yeah it's like when you find that that
the best part of a potato was the peel
yeah like I would put that to pay like a
friend of mine we were talking about a
restaurant yeah being your girlfriend
what's the name Oh Jesse I love today
she's awesome
you know we're talking about a
restaurant in Boulder that I really came
up with them like it's really weird when
you come up with somebody yeah when I
was starting to go to that restaurant
nobody really went to that restaurant
and after I started going there
because of the old and then we ended up
at the halfway house together his
personality blew the place up
yeah him being in a halfway house ain't
no word got on the street
white people like that they wanted to do
business with him but they didn't but he
was such a great chef he had such a
great Italian restaurant he had grappa
which nobody even knew a cropper was
that alcohol yeah
broke his he had shot two grappa there
were 15 a shot I don't know what that is
at 95 with DZ O's and bold back then was
my [ __ ] I was in there my wife
[ __ ] why'd she hate it because I was
there every minute I could be there oh
she hated that you were there she didn't
hate the restaurant no no nobody hated I
said she did you were always there yeah
cuz it was my people that that's my type
environment crazy ex crime ex-cons he
was an ex-con but his wife was a
reverend is a reverend mrs. Enloe away
yeah she has her own church in bold
outside of Boulder and then the whining
cooks my taser there's a the bakery guy
there the guy that was the bacon remedy
Zeos in 1991 him and I still talk every
two weeks know that [ __ ] I am
Joe Koch he just sold his bagel shop in
Mississippi the whole thing did you work
there you would just go and hang out
after work hey I loved his right I love
that his wife is a go behind the counter
and do whatever is necessary pick up the
phone you help me yes okay come in it's
for you Joey
go back then give me a case of beer back
there this guy needs a case of beer and
I would eat like how all the mistakes
[Laughter]
always in the back like [ __ ] up the
foods and we gave the chef a $5 bill
like hey I'm looking for sausage and
pepper oh no and I bring a weed
restaurant I'm that guy that hangs that
restaurant I love it I hung there I had
a Chinese restaurant ball that hung on
it but I became French because they were
gambling addicts were they Chinese
people Chinese people I would torment
them they were Vietnamese but they posed
as Chinese see it's not sick there were
nice people is this the one that you
scammed
I didn't scam it might never scanned him
I was friends don't
it was really weird I was broke I was a
good customer and one day I wanted food
and I forgot that I had money like I
forgot where I put my money I was so
high when I was like before and when
they came to liver I go listen I don't
believe this I forget me I'll just drop
it off when you have it so when I was
going through my thing from 94 to 95
when I was broke I can always call them
up and get food on the arm oh and they
would run a tab for me and I would pay
them like every two weeks on Friday
it means Chinese food how much could it
be bucks well but I would get three
sodas yeah you don't have to a coke
binge ravenous you want four [ __ ]
cans of coke then we get an order which
are hot and sour soup let me get two
orders had gross let me get an order of
[ __ ] crab rings I have eaten the
weirdest [ __ ] when I come down from Kobe
I eat whatever's one night I remember
all I had in my freezer was frozen
vegetables and I had no foods so I
heated up a bowl of frozen Brussels
spouts Brussels sprouts nothing on it I
was like 4:00 in the morning and I was
laying in bed eating one with my fingers
like the ball because I was so hungry
and I didn't know how to get any food my
neighborhood is too scary to go out
after like one it's definitely like
total hood you've been I don't know if
you try my neighborhood is like super
sketchy because they were building a
target in the neighborhood three years
ago and then someone in the neighborhood
said that targets too tall it blocks my
view of the Hollywood sign which this
neighborhood is so far from the
Hollywood sign you can't even see it
from any of the buildings but this old
dude complained so the city looked into
it and it turned out the target is seven
inches above city code so the city made
target stop building it they said you
either have to tear it down and start
over or we have to change the laws that
was three years ago the building is
still empty so now it's turned into like
a homeless apartment complex it's like a
thousand homeless people living in this
target and it's in my neighborhood so it
went
I moved in like there's gonna be a
target it's gonna be awesome here it's
gonna get like more expensive and now
it's turned into the slums you can walk
that target and buy drugs how far you
from the Hollywood I'm I'm like two
miles from the comedy star I'm near like
Western and in Hollywood oh yeah that's
scary yeah it's so bad Joey there's ten
villages was it your first place in LA
no that's the thing I kind of went
backwards like I had wayne ivey Italian
or something like that that's Thai town
same thing right so you live on an awful
western sunset like Western in Hollywood
that area oh yeah it's crazy
it's so bad but it didn't used to be it
used to be it was like gentrifying and
then it went back when gentrify for a
while yeah western the hollywood is
where they used to be at i thing there
there still is a little Thai setting
like a post office mailbox placed next
to a restaurant yeah that corner yeah
old finger that's a great place that
place that did the massages and
everything yeah that little complex is
good but a few blocks down it's like I
mean seriously it's walk down towards
Western all way from Western walk down
towards sunset so it's basically like
Western and sunset like where the Home
Depot is like that close it turns from
like nice like Starbucks to like a tent
city no joke like bonfires and trash
cans at night it's so bad it's so sever
been scared
I've lived in South Side Chicago I've
never been scared and I'm a brown belt
like I'm tough you know I'm scared there
now I won't even walk at night do you
mind if I ask you why nobody what you
pay for rent just because like it's it's
crazy and LU like you think you're
living in the ghetto and then it's like
1,500 I pay 14 for a one-bedroom but
that's because it's rent-controlled when
I moved in it was 1325 for a one-bedroom
with parking but in my neighborhood now
it's like 1800 for a one-bedroom in that
ghetto a Hollywood was [ __ ] scary
when I moved here it's still scary guys
you know I've been hit with talk I'm
telling you this podcast it wasn't I
wasn't scared like San Francisco scary
at night when they 85 or New York City
Harlem scared no it has a different type
it's different it's different because
you're not expecting it it's also things
get weird
it's different because it's not scary
like violent scary like they're gonna
Rob you scary it's scary because the
people seem crazy that are on this but
no no Hollywood Boulevard the other
night I went to Hollywood just to kill
time I did not feel like doing standouts
not like you I had to meet our friend
how to meet new people
oh yeah that night I haven't meet a
friend about the dog the other friend
about a dog for a script yeah heaven
give me a script so I met a friend to
buy the dog I go down to pick up
something good so I'm gonna pick up
something bad on there that's cold where
I gotta pick something up okay what are
you gonna do I got him to see a man
about a dog
about a dog that's the cold word and it
means I'm not gonna tell you what I'm
doing yeah I just gotta go do something
that you you don't want to be involved I
thought maybe you were getting mercy a
puppy even mercy knows my daughter knows
she does when I tell her you'll see a
man about she don't ask my gosh she's
five she don't ask she knows that she's
like yeah I'm getting a dog now she's
like she's getting a dog right it's an
expression like even my wife was this
straight as can be I could top my wife
I'm gonna see a man in my dog and she
knows how lonely he think pick up a gun
what I'm going to see something illegal
and you can't come yeah
so that's what I went to see a man about
a dog so when I went down and I went to
see this duo dude who actually had work
for me but then my other boy caught me
he goes does your boy still need that
thing I got it from I said [ __ ] I'm
gonna I also take [ __ ] with me I was
gonna send him on the mission and you
were gonna come see me and he gots good
what happened tell me because I let this
is what happens he got scared as he gets
he starts with his whining wrong with
you you have no idea and I even called
him and said right now I'm at Joe's
pizza having the best lice I have a
house and I bring you I didn't want to
know
I'm gonna offer about two thing because
why talked about when I take to be ready
in five minutes don't worry we need to
go then we'll you up might have to do
something first of all you might have to
do something he gets good he get scared
what's gonna happen to me I need to know
I don't want to take no illegal drugs
sale right now first of all this weekend
he gave me an expired edible expired she
would chew how can an edible expire was
there's food stuff in it like was it a
gummy what was no it was like a little
like two years old it was like [ __ ]
odd boy
what's a chocolate I'm used to that by
now he called me I wish I could remember
the day and I could look at my phone he
probably called me 18 times and every
time he said I'll be there in 10 minutes
I was ready you got me so why are you
scared
why are you scared of things you also
wouldn't touch my friends but tonight no
first of all I worry if you're out there
I would love to touch your butt but you
told me to be to Victor oh my god I'm
gonna get you me too
please do something but you say that I
would have and yeah I'm sorry if he
calls me and tells me weird I got the
heroin that killed Michael Jack whatever
he says yeah I remember that I get a
little nervous I'm not gonna pretend
like I don't the heroin is the cocaine
that killed that basketball players
everything but before you think this is
too soon what about when he said it like
[ __ ] tonight oh this is the week Kate
Spade at the bag my buddy John bender
who I dearly love is doing something
they're doing like my peoples night out
in North Bergen its August night
people's night out yes you go to the
parks and there they they have hot dogs
and the people will donate stuff they're
donating [ __ ]
Spade bags at this so all these people
going through this barbecue was a
popular thing yeah I want a Kate Spade
bag I'm gonna ten black dicks up my ass
right now you understand me
like if a black dick was walking down
the street - I'd rather have him knock
on the door than a Kate batts maid bag
right now it wouldn't be for you no boy
first no it's a kiss of death company
anymore
I gotta spit on myself because it's bad
[ __ ] can say that's like I've never
been like I've never been into that kind
of [ __ ] like I have I don't like to shop
and I don't like to have a lot of stuff
she thinks she's mush now like the dog I
don't want his money around my money was
Kate Spade really cool like when was
aids big what I didn't know nothing
about it does she kill this how [ __ ]
crazy is that that's how out of it I am
I don't even know I was thinking of the
wrong person I was thinking of the model
that really skinny model chick that's
not her Kate Spade's the designer chick
see I don't even know I don't pay
attention the Anthony Bourdain thing I
actually felt really bags I didn't look
at the news all day till like 1:00 a.m.
so I was like tweeting jokes all day and
then I saw somebody even wrote me
something about Anthony Bourdain like
rip Anthony Bourdain it didn't occur to
me that he died I don't know what I was
like what the [ __ ] is he talking about
he's hi I'm really bad about keeping up
I don't watch TV I mean listen there's
so much information getting thrown at
you from all directions it's not even
that about him from how much information
yeah
it's grown at the human brain today is
the human brain designed yeah what's
going on today
you know people getting brain tumors
from cellphones today I had a
conversation with someone at my
daughter's swimming and he's a little
old fashioned like I am we were talking
about the disadvantages of the cell
phone and what the cell phone you know
has great advantages yeah but the
disadvantage is the biggest there's a
lot you know what the biggest
disadvantage of this
always breathing like I laugh because
you're not living you know what you're
so right I don't even look I write laugh
at people okay I'm sorry I'm speaking I
am ashamed because people always go to
me every two weeks I get it I get hate
mail and it's always that I'm telling a
lie the stories to the thought of that
let me tell you something my friend I
never I lived the life I was out there I
lived when I was that's why I get mad at
Lee you know yes it was probably my
fault that least stayed out there Monday
night Friday night in Vegas for your
book guess what came what else would he
have done that night he's got a garden
adventure he will he got home at 11:30
with D'Agostino put on well I was stupid
[ __ ] he's watching on [ __ ] Netflix
and down on social media and jerked off
and gone to bed you know you know what
he didn't turn into an adventure because
he didn't want it he sat next to an
African check and there was Mexican
criminals on board you know whatever on
the plane of the gray hat how am I
supposed to turn the bus into an
adventure interview all of them on life
from the lights off it's 1:00 in the
morning it's it's so weird how we have
forgot how to live like a half the
comics if I tell if I get down with you
I come you come over and we stay up all
night talking like this [ __ ] I used to
do in Greyhound in the 1919 no no not
that [ __ ] I used to do in Graham but my
life on the Greyhound bus for three
years you know Ralphie may used to laugh
at me I used to be embarrassed to tell
other comics that I would leave in
tonight so I would go they would go
where you going this week I'm gonna go
pass up I think Oh what time is your
flight that you want I think it's out of
LAX an eight o'clock and I would lie the
other comics why were you taking the bus
because I had a saved money I was only
getting five budget to feature yeah yeah
yeah $500 to feature yeah from Tuesday
to Saturday okay
so 500 if that in those days it was $80
each way on Southwest and that's if you
want the ticket three weeks in advance
yeah so that's one sick
see out of 500 what does that leave you
with 343 [ __ ] 40 buy food food taxes
and pay bills pay yeah no please
and pay bills so you know 340 but the
Greyhounds dirty five [ __ ] dollars
that'll pass at the time was 1750 each
way Wow
as long as that right 11 hours out of
your life that's not the two and a half
but when you think about it and when
you're a comic you think of 11 hours and
what does a comic pray for in his life
solitude yeah that's a solitude you need
I would go on that Greyhound bus I put
your phones on with a discman I have a
discman [ __ ] Christine Aggie era and
I would get a notebook and I would stay
up all night and I would roll the joint
and every time the bus stopped David
don't say this this must have stopping
for an hour
go eat so and the food was horrible I
mean it was it was like eating pure but
at least I was smoking and then I
started learning to bring my own food on
the buses but I would add you know no
you really have restaurants at this day
to have restaurants in the station so
right now you know right now like right
now if I were to right now if I got a
call right now okay it's what night is
it cheese Wednesday it's Tuesday night
it's nine o'clock right now the [ __ ]
phone rings and they say to me Joey we
have a gig for you tomorrow a week that
starts tomorrow night and we've
California and then from there it goes
to Baba Baba Baba but you're working
with a girl named Kate Quigley if I say
to the Booker what do I do
you know like what do I do like I don't
have a car the book of will go well
Kate's gonna drive she's headlining
you're gonna open up for Kate but tell
Kate we Kato meet you at the first gate
yeah so I would have to get myself to
afford it so right now I would get on
the phone call Greyhound 1-800 whatever
the number was no grand no [ __ ] money
there was no Greyhound back yeah no no
went underground and you gotta [ __ ]
call and go
man I want to go to [ __ ] weed
California and where's your destination
LA downtown okay there's the bust is 11
but now you still gotta get that you
know you know where the bus stop is
running around there right in the valley
no the corner oh yeah by the big Wang's
that that big trains not big but with no
whole diner it down the corner from the
down the corner from there it's the size
of this office it's the size this office
a great huh yeah I almost did that one
but I would have taken two I would've
had to wait two hours in LA to get the
bust of me oh yeah it goes right there
that's right you if you drive behind the
air right after the haha you always see
people standing no way so what they do
is they walk to know hold I know so the
bus will drop you off you have a
three-hour wait where do you go that's
why the no whole diner is open 24 hours
Wow because people would take a bus
don't know how diamond yeah
but that's when you're a comic like
that's like it's like that Bon Jovi was
in that video by Bon Jovi wanted that or
a while yeah when he's on the bus and
the guys playing the drums but they show
him looking out a window on the bus like
that was my life guys no man you know
what I did the same thing not with
comedy because I've been very blessed
that people like you will take me to
feature and will get me a flight in a
hotel room so I'm not taking a greyhound
but I used to do I think I told you I
used to emcee events and I used to do
like promotional marketing gigs like
state fairs and stuff and they would
give us flight money and hotel money but
the gig wouldn't pay that much so I
would say sure the blight money so I
would this is actually I forgot I even
did this I would rent like an SUV and I
would park at truckstops
or sometimes if there was a like a
u-haul truck for the gig like if they
were bringing product I'd ask the driver
if I could ride with him to the next
stop and I would sleep in the back of
the truck on those furniture pads one
time I was working an event for dog food
at state fairs I was like talking about
dog food on a microphone to like
everyone at the fair before the country
singer would come on stage I'd have to
be like ten minutes
of talking about dog food and I would
sleep in the back of that [ __ ] budget
truck with the dog food at truckstops
and I would just lock it from the inside
like there was a way you could lock it
and sleep in there for whole summers
this it's a dream and I would shower in
the trucks table but I would make an
extra like thousand like ten fifty or
something a week because I wasn't paying
for hotels truck stops
it's like a [ __ ] massage parlor yeah
you pay you go in there they even have a
bed they have like a little more like
movie views having some of them don't
they have like really nice well some are
really nice actually like the pilot ones
I'm not gonna like jump stop oh my god
when I was a teenager I would go to
truck stop so right like when I was a
kid I used to write music I play guitar
I would go to truck stops in the middle
of the night this one I was like 14 15
and sit and write and talk to the truck
drivers like I always liked truck stops
and I always liked Drifters something
about drifter it's probably why I like
you because you have the soul of like a
drifter because you're probably always
like hiding from people do you ever like
I used to think I would love it I'm sure
like I'm sure doesn't pay great I'm sure
it's not super good but I like being by
myself and all that so like I could very
easily see myself doing it listen I have
no qualms with I have a wife and a child
right yeah yeah I would love to be able
to get the car with you and Kate and do
the 24 hour drive to Houston listen
you've never laughed that hard in your
life we would laugh the intent we drive
you don't know what it's like to drive
with comics and that camaraderie with
people that you really careful with to
comics that were really cool well Umesh
was like I was talking to Dean Del Ray
and he was telling me that he had a gig
once and makers feel when he first
started and they had to drive up there
with two comics that were miserable
oh he goes it was the worst driver my
life I'll they were both telling me to
quit then it's all chains that you have
to you know do all these things but that
all flips when you get the car with
people that you care about it's
hysterical
and I use shrimp like somebody's gotta
be sober you know the driver
I just love pot that's how it's a rescue
mother like that you call that sober
yeah I'm so just smoking dope I'm in
charge of the music you tweeze in charge
of the directions and you're in charge
of saying pull over after this one cuz I
got a pee sleep in the truck stops and
that's so fun I used to go so this is
the rally this is the route I used to
take josh will turn me on to a website
back then that you went out to the
airport you stood on line you got to the
window it's something completely
different that's a Jersey Mike's now you
don't go to LAX
I know Jersey Mike before you go to LAX
there's a Jersey Mike's on century
Boulevard okay on the right hand side
yeah there used to be a place that you
went there by the hotel by the hotel you
wanted a you said I wanna go to New York
tonight and then get you a fight for a
hundred bucks
why but they treat you like a Puerto
Rican they lose your luggage big [ __ ]
secured airlines inspirited somebody you
bought tickets last minute huh and I
would take one of those but how I would
get back in it would be by bus so I
would land in Newark
one of my friends would pick me up I go
to his house take a shower eat and then
we'd get weed coke my party and then the
next morning he dropped me off at Port
Authority in New York City and from that
you could get all around the world on a
[ __ ] bus it'd be fine if you did it
with your friends it would and I would
take a bus all the way to Buffalo and
then my friend from Miami he was so this
is how Comedy Works I had a friend and
buffalo well I had a friend in Miami
well his brother his brother his brother
waiters at the improv
yeah is one both good-looking white
dudes from New York one so called heavy
duty and the other one just snorted coke
can be doing it and he a Chinese with
the one that's not a coke heavy duty but
he dated a Puerto Rican girl so I would
I would start or I would take a flight
to my hair
worked two weeks of Miami and then from
Miami I would take an Amtrak to Myrtle
Beach damn that's a long time that was
brutal
yeah and that's the Myrtle Beach I would
go to DC I would do Tyson's Corner
Virginia Bethesda Maryland the DC and
problem with John X was booking
individual take buses to all this place
this is all be black box but the Train
is so much nice it's primal way more
expensive but the trip is expensive it's
almost as much as because I'll tell you
why yeah it's 160 to go out of it that's
for a chair
really oh you want a seat belt oh that's
$1 yeah oh you want a blanket that's
another 12 oh you don't want to sit next
to a Chinese guy in action
oh you want to fill a chair that
requires that's a little $18 oh wait a
second that's special tonight yeah for
dinner have you ever been up on the
train no because the one time I was
gonna do it it was the same as flying
really well here's how the Train works
you ready yeah you get to the caboose
where they give you food it's salad soup
- egg roll appetizer a main dinner and
dessert and free wine and coffee so they
want 30 bucks with a whole thing you go
over there you go listen what if I don't
want the salad the dessert of whatever
can I just get the [ __ ] entree no you
didn't get the whole thing yeah
so it was just like a ripoff for me so I
never took the train again I don't know
what he's talking about
this trains from Boston to New York
doesn't like those trains so yeah like
like what that fool John did when I
worked problems he took a train right
Penn Station that's like the railroad is
that like Boston to New York is for
buses - I did that eight thousand times
I can't imagine being going like I even
looked from LA to Boston just once on
greyhound it's just--see and i think
it's like two three days grey how do you
look if I just see what it was there's
no Express it's such a weird thing
though you know you stop and Lync
Express there is an Express Greyhound LA
to Boston on a greyhound
that's so crazy though [ __ ] days
thank you like a [ __ ] hell oh that
sounds like you know who does that Eric
Myers you know Eric Myers the little do
you guys know him the comic is from
Florida kind of a scrawny dude super
funny guys gots he's terrified to fly so
bad he's an addict right but he's sober
but if he flies it's pushed him off the
wagon before so he's too scared so he'll
take a [ __ ] bus from Florida to LA
every time back and forth you have no
ideas you have no idea what it's like to
be on a bus I've taken buses from Philly
to New York like to our city now
remember one time I went to New York on
a Sunday and my week at ieveis yeah in
Dallas started on my [ __ ] Thursday
and I made plans with a friend of mine
when I was not called then do all these
[ __ ] things
can I put away all this money in Dallas
no in New York I got to New York I
realized I couldn't get a hold him he
had been had a different coat for a man
before so here I am what they said they
wait for him I checked into a hotel room
again I drank I dropped back eight hours
and I'm like [ __ ] $80 I don't know what
it was at that time this was like this
is this is feature Monica yeah yeah yeah
no I'm saying that's a good deal yeah I
was gonna meet her even alive anymore
he died in 99 so he's had to be 98 I was
making out to 400 a week done and I had
a week I found a flight out of Canada to
Dallas right 90 bucks long like a melt
like 160 or something but it was a
tremendous flight so I was gonna wait to
three days and I'm in the city I went
into the city I bought some coke
I had my luggage with me like my family
luggage and what I did was when I landed
a Port Authority could put your [ __ ] in
lockers so I put my [ __ ] in a locker and
my girlfriend of mine I couldn't get
ahold of him so I did what I usually do
I took a train I took the A train uptown
I picked up two grams to two routes I
picked up a couple nickel bags up a
couple Pete backs of rolling papers I
picked up a few liners I would took of a
train back to Times Square Boston see
these
and I said you know what I think it'll
wait till Thursday pay a bunch of money
to stay in the hotel and blow all my
money on coke with these guys why could
take the grant hey was the Express to
Dallas how not bad I mean you know what
sometimes when I fly
you always everyone always asks if I
sleep I never sleep because I love I get
more work done in a six hour flight on a
plane where no one can bother me and
it's completely quiet and dark then I
ever do in like two days at my apartment
so if I was on a bus for three days
I'd probably write a whole script yeah I
don't know what [ __ ] done that's why
it's not that bad as a comedian when you
travel you're like when do I need to be
there Thursday I got two options
yeah I could [ __ ] lived there for two
days hand-to-mouth and live in a budget
or just be on a bus for two days yeah it
kind of sucks but it's just a day now
they have Wi-Fi on this bus yes why for
not that bad dad buses not a pretty
Pinto like they have the Mexican bust El
Paso that's a complete different bus of
Mexican but that's the Mexican people
which run by Mexicans and companies like
an old school musical and they have
Telemundo somebody sells tamales on
there I like that they have that but
they also have the Greyhound you know I
like I said I just I had I had a lot of
long trips on greyhounds I had a couple
sexual
I cannot imagine meeting a guy on a bus
on a bus across country a greyhound and
hooking up before we got to the stop
like I can't even imagine that happening
to me but that would be my favorite
story I had I had a hook-up on a plane
one time a night when I had a girlfriend
no way I got on the plane and I started
making out with this girl on a plane
next you don't finger in the black how
did that happen I have no [ __ ] idea
each drunken habit from the night before
so is she as she was with her friends as
she switched seats to sit next to me
like I'd met her at the airport
oh you met her before you got on the
flight yeah like we met at the bomb I'm
21 at the time that's nuts
I met my ex-wife
no way yeah I can meet one example when
I was young I gotta stop I'm gonna start
looking p.m. what's the party's three
twenty years ago flying was completely
different than what it is today in
America thirty years ago
yeah there's no like 40-pound pitbull on
your flight deck there was no animals
there was no nation security was very
lacks I'm a madman Culkin a jacket one
time they told me I'd take my jacket off
and I remembered that I had to call him
like the inside pocket like it was like
I had like a shirt a tire yeah and the
guy was about to go in then something
made him like stop because I go through
and that was it why would he check your
jacket planes would different python
coins or keys planes with different back
that like a red-eye in the eighties
meant red eyes weren't for decent people
shut up none really and I look for
degenerates you get in turn the lights
off on a [ __ ] flight in the eighties
and nineties on a [ __ ] rata I wish
they still have flights how great if
they had a done only flights that were
like other people knew what we was
drinking yeah you like the red tunnel
and buy him a beer next thing you know
I'm buying you a drink on the plane next
you know the lady I'm sitting next is
she's a [ __ ] boring [ __ ] so we're
gonna move on listen you might as well
move over that cuz we're gonna talk all
night and next you know there'd be three
rows like you know there's no eighteen
people talk bro you have no [ __ ] idea
at one time being at an airport getting
delayed in Denver this is when the last
flight to Aspen was nine o'clock and
getting delayed and Anne had done was
stapled to the airport and then meeting
a guy and the guys like dog that powder
and me and him the bars of sale help you
talk to or three and we're at this bar
just bumping and we kept chasing bars
wait what bars open he has got a
terminal Dee's got a bar had the coke
kid that's the same that had like 12
ounces of coke as I was going to New
York to pick up coke and I would bring
it to Denver then sometimes the flight
would get delayed so I put in one of
those
walkers in the airport and the airport
don't have those lockers I put the coke
in there I take a grandma to out it's
like a bump freely at the bar with
somebody I'd meet it's so different now
then I would go back they'd oh my god
you could never even find a locker I
remember my flight one of the best
flights I was ever on was that listen to
me guys listen to me but Lee Lee is my
friend
I love Lee Lee gave me one of the best
compliments he ever gave me today he
didn't even know he gave me a backhanded
compliment but it meant the world to me
he said I know all the people you did
business with the only one that worked
out from was a guy who went to prison
and some of you kidnapped somebody but
everybody else fell apart Lee knows how
long I'll struggle to mind I had when I
got on the plane
July 1st 1985 when I got on that plane I
was headed to Colorado Springs Colorado
yeah but because of a faulty drug black
dude the flight that we were drinking
with he talked me into going to Boulder
I went to both my life is the way it is
today because of a drunk I met on the
plane that came from wrote n2 wrote 20
because in those days you know what I do
to you may I come back there and hit you
and we talked for a little while in
those days you could stand in the aisles
and a beer yes like to talk to you like
what's up check was honest that's right
what's going on with you and your world
looking with your finances [ __ ] let me
buy you a cocktail oh my god in those
days I would meet people and I'm plains
no way so in those days first classes
upstairs if you watch the movie Midnight
Run first class used to be upstairs
there was an airline that I went on one
time that the [ __ ] there was a pig with
an apple in its mouth when you got on
there that's how strong the last Wang
used to be phenomenal perfumes hand
creams in first class in the bathrooms
yet flying has changed dramatically but
what changed the most was the party
aspect of the flight you how many
[ __ ] flights I got on with 12 people
were doing blow and drinking you're in
the middle
plain Gurkha got people moving their
hands and [ __ ] [ __ ] people giving
cocktail wait what else this is 20 I was
like keep bringing the [ __ ] boxes
everybody was in on it
no well Mon could you imagine being on
you said you left somebody'd want cake
can you imagine though you like you have
nowhere I be I'm with like a flower
flying used to be a party that would be
so fun if they did that now they should
have a doll only you can't you can't
[ __ ] party no more I was on a plane
three years ago what huh let's be honest
let's be honest I'll be honest with you
people these people were being loud but
they weren't bothered everybody here six
people who were just going to a bachelor
party okay you know what that's like
nine college friends will go into a
passive Park yeah a great what now 29
yeah five a married four of them have a
kid yeah I'm saying yeah they're out to
verify only got together they were
sitting behind me on a plane on a
Southwest flight from Burbank to Vegas
and well sure it went into cocktails
that and the [ __ ] pilot came back
then said before we take off I just
won't let you guys know that there's not
gonna be any and the guy goes come on
give him the plan and give us a cocktail
the pilot turned around three minutes
later he came back home with three
police guys know next thing you know
[ __ ] they opened up the back door and
four cops got in the back and they said
who said that to the pilot that made the
guy embarrassed raised his hand and they
said this was gonna do you got two
options you get off the plane right now
we book you tomorrow morning or you
could take us to kids are like we know
our rights and they started taking the
cameras out and then we know our rights
or the time the cop said or will close
the plant you could take the flight but
when you touch down in Vegas Vegas PD
will be waiting for you
you're gonna get arrested and guess what
else you're not gonna see the judge till
Monday what you're asking for a cocktail
from the pilot I'm the pilot to go on
the back I had a plan and get me a
cocktail that was a joke and then 20
years ago the pilot with a giggles and
said I
see you guys another party all right
I'll see you in Vegas the pilot went and
came back with three [ __ ] cops and
they backed the [ __ ] plane the cops
came on they were riot gear dog and the
cop came on and then that's exactly told
the set nine people got up and got off
the plane that's exactly I did
everything I thought was in the scene
and Eyewitness News cop told the truth
how long ago was that maybe maybe a year
ago you know night flight delayed or
something yes the last time I went to
the South Point like this we come at the
South no way it was a year ago July
Vegas come on of course they're gonna be
like TV show about it don't play good
old plan I get nervous to even tweet
jokes about flights when I'm on the
plane play one time when you had a walk
outside first yeah that was doing call
it was Sunday and I started doing coke
on Friday and it was the wintertime
everybody had a jacket on and I had a
thermal t-shirt on my bodies I was get
on the plane the store this is the guy
you okay I'm for help and I'm coked up
to the gills and I'm gone the plan
hasn't even taken off with my blast I'm
getting up every a blast people put
their luggage away I'm blasting I've
gotten up 20 times before the plane even
took off no and then the plane started
getting packed on people started sitting
next to me and I couldn't get up you
know and I started putting the thing
down I put the blanket on my head I was
the biggest coke fiend this is right
before I know what you're doing right
listen had to I would go to the bathroom
pull my pants down okay and make believe
I was [ __ ] and I would hide like I
wouldn't let my damaris in my head
because I thought there was a camera a
two-way cache you know me I wonder if
there is a camera yeah and you got to
think twice and I would do a little
bunch of coke and I would jerk off a
little bit [ __ ] about the plane and then
I would wipe my ass like that like fake
it like I was taking a [ __ ] and I would
wipe my ass of a camera would think I
was wiping when you're paranoid your
mind tells you this [ __ ]
one time that same glad I got out and
when I walked out I left the toilet
paper and my pants are they dragged into
the [ __ ] always somebody had to stop
me and go you got toilet paper
I was discussed I never was a disgusting
I never thought about cameras in there I
I've taken like hot photos in there
though you know I was on the plane one
time with you and I was gonna go back
there and say can't take a picture you
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] I'm sitting up here a bit
by myself I could bang bang without on
planes before I have first class oh I
rub one out like I was gonna say that
that means he didn't do it in the
bathroom I don't put him back the jig
well I pay a lot of my plane ticket well
you're in like a little booth no yes
cappuccino stop I saw a guy jerking off
in front of the 7-eleven under a blanket
but it was so obvious what he was doing
because you could see the blanket moving
up and down and I pull it in it's just
last week I pulled him and it was so
awkward because I was looking right at
him and he was looking right in total
eye contact the [ __ ] kind of Christian
are you popular at that situation I
couldn't get out of the car for a minute
and I was like I can't walk by these
guys to embarrass you do you really do
it cappuccino style I like quickly
enough so no one would see I wanna play
on asleep and keep my head like this to
look for this doing this cappuccino stop
and at the end you come in your hand and
just keep it down like a little gurgle
then you get one of those that means you
wipe around you help me you slip it back
in your pants and for a minute until you
have that coming like your palm in your
hand it starts like what is the hamlet
eyes just starts to get
that in will you wash it how is it
possible I was telling you before the
podcast that I did a podcast the other
day and it was with a mom and her son
called like sex talk with mom or
something and they watched a few
episodes of us together and they were
saying she said I saw Joey talking about
anal and how it he doesn't like anal
because he doesn't like if he gets poop
on his dick and she was like is he
vanilla when it comes to sex he seems a
little vanilla and I was like I don't
think so last night he was telling me
about when he came on a spoon and fed it
to a chicks
I was like I wouldn't call that vanilla
why did you feed your come to a woman
how did that happen you told me you
jerked off into a spoon and fed it to
her coked up with existence somebody was
a form of imagination how did you why
did you she was such a dirty and having
to think of a spoon I was just looking
at like what can I do to her that would
be different than anybody else did that
I want her to remember me for the rest
of my life can't forget and she went one
over there with a spoon just an off into
the spool any like she sucked my dick
she didn't even ask me why do you have a
spoon again she thought like it was like
a tuna the whole time like I just I
thought about it I went oh you dick man
they're sucking your dick on the coke
and then when I came I squirted someone
a face but I squirted some on the spoon
and she just looked at me like she
thought I was going to drink it
what's it twice what to make sure it
tastes okay okay that's good no just to
see what the [ __ ] come in when you're
like 12 that was like 12
you never say anything over Thomas ever
again how dare you like you think so why
would you smell it I never tasted it
like a little finger when you're 13
every guy has taste really how they
don't know every [ __ ] I began with
dear we do what it's gonna be in the
face before we do with our survey with
me 82% of men have tasted their own come
when they were 12 13 the first one to 20
as High Times they came you should taste
it why to make sure to taste your soul
yeah
I don't taste it to see how it tasted to
test it to see I don't give a [ __ ]
that's your job you put up with this
[ __ ] crazy glue that's coming out of
my dick I'm gonna worry about what it
tastes like I'm a manufacturer of Cola
manufacturers a firm it comes out you
drink it that's really bad you can
control no you can yes you can you can I
do my diet no listen listen let me trace
it telling when you look at a dick it's
disgusting but what comes out of a man's
dick is even more disgusting only one
person could drink that [ __ ] and it's
you lunatics nobody else could drink
that [ __ ] that is disgusting this glass
and I've had women who have looked me in
the face and someone could drink gallons
of it like I had I wouldn't drink out I
drink it to be nice like it's a rising
at that ones I think they do drink oh my
god yeah I play it up you know make you
feel good about it yeah you were really
you but I don't know if I would drink it
off a spoon to be honest if you're coked
up with me if it's 48 hours listen I'll
take it and [ __ ] blow it into ass
with a flute at that point yeah I'll be
like what are you playing Indian music
for the same thing theme music but you
feel like going to beer [ __ ] knows
I'm crazy oh my god
that cocaine [ __ ] used to make me
[ __ ] crazy
it's weird though with me what's coke
honestly because if it's a few bumps it
makes me way hornier and I'll do
anything
it does coke every idea you have on coke
is the best idea you've ever had no
matter what but there is some point
where I get too high and I don't want to
[ __ ] if I do too much it makes me like
it's creeps you a [ __ ] up it does get
your creep that I've had yeah and it
makes your mouth dry is hard to suck a
dick or the dry mouth and I need a lot
of water and then it's like if the sex
is really good I'm like breathing hard
and then I keep getting thirsty I get
one guy one time was so good and I kept
on being like wait I need to drink and
he was like are you okay and I was like
yeah you're just so good and he think I
scared it there's gonna be guys with
going you two bumps and all your shows
now just look it's great
cuz I thought
well I first thought doing cocaine the
sex was tremendous the sex was from for
me from 84 they're like 80 no from 84 to
lamely 596 the sucks on cocaine was
something with the right crazy girl you
were perfectly girl when we used to
roofie each other
in Boulder like that one she was crazy
that was great and I was friends with my
mom and I'd have to face her mom and
that stand her mom ago since did you
guys have a good time last night she
didn't know we were having sex she
thought we were just friends she didn't
know that her daughter was a [ __ ]
animal degree that's what I'm talking
about who I put the coke I'm the spoon
that time she drank it like it was
[ __ ] the Molson of God it was
tremendous but at that time I wasn't
getting hard-ons either ki-43 the more
there's nothing there that's why I'm
just short sometimes that you can get
become evil
I become evil to you I start fingering
you were four fingers whipping it all
this [ __ ] you like choking you slapping
your balls making you suck balls making
your tongue my ass or why you play with
yourself then I just say play with
yourself nice touch and watch it explain
yourself I'll give you the rocks of coke
like that scene and then one with Jack
Nicholson what's that movie did where he
plays why he Bulger deducted when he's
getting high with the two chicks in
Black Mass did he go no oh wait the
department department is in the morning
yeah well he's doing coke with them he
throws the coke atom like that's how
crazy I used to get I like all that
craziness that's when you get a girl to
[ __ ] you know suck a little [ __ ] and
I can get you to eat her that's my thing
with you to eat her well I [ __ ] you
from behind so while you're eating hair
I'm [ __ ] you from
that is a package that's like my life I
dreamed that I would switch places
oh I would switch places and I would
have the one sister go that with me and
I'd finger the other ones [ __ ] I was
crazy but I was crazy
95 crazy and I met the stripper that she
out crazily she's doing that taught me
about smack and then choke ended [ __ ]
thrown across the room and calling her a
[ __ ] animal choking and dragging her
across the floor Porter she wanted me to
pull by a hand across the floor one time
like a [ __ ] caveman like oh my god
that's hot that's what turned around and
I dated a Korean girl in Boulder that
the only way you can have sex with her
is by her ripping the outfit off her
outfit are yours
you had to rip her outfit off that is
really hot to do that I'm talking about
they rip it apart she has to leave in
your clothes like she have to leave like
sweat except that's hot had a gay
brother
she had a gay brother and she would come
in I've been walking with her and she'd
look at this and she'd go rough night
last night I would rip her clothes off
everything underwear socks pants she
wanted you to rip her clothes apart and
I would leave her panties on throughout
this whole thing I would eat her [ __ ]
with the panties on guys love that and
then I would rip her [ __ ] panties off
but then she charged me 40 for a brawl
one time cuz the bra was a good run
that's hilarious
first as a [ __ ] 42 for a brawl
are you kidding me expensive you better
start getting those 3 for $10 think
Papa's coming home for Thanksgiving you
know that's how it is with me with that
guy's yeah a lot of people white people
like when you rip their clothes off it's
different and that's the adventures of
life guys that's not being the me to
this is what happens when you choose a
life of debauchery no what did you call
us before us what what you call you call
us a name grifters Harris Harris this is
what we do is convenience there's 15 to
18% most other grifters there's this son
gene you have inside of you that makes
you want to
it's like a jiff not something about you
today like you've always been an
entertainer yeah at 14 but you've also
always flirted on the line of I think it
raped you have a truck station like what
I always like danger a little rest yeah
always I say hitchhike when I was really
young to like I just like always I think
it's because I always like doing what
people said I couldn't do you know so
whatever it was don't hitchhike don't
hang out at truck stops don't smoke
don't do I always wanted to look back at
it now and go jesus [ __ ] christ
that's crazy did you meet creepy people
yeah but I also met really cool amazing
people and I think I learned that
there's a lot more good people than bad
people like in my in my experience I've
met a lot of people that have really
cool stories like I remember meeting I
hitchhiked I forgot about this in Ohio I
took a run oh I picked up a hitchhiker I
picked up the hitchhiker I was 16 I
picked this guy up
he was a Rastafarian black dude he's
from Jamaica I don't know why he was in
Ohio but it was raining and storming and
I felt bad for him so I gave him a ride
it's the first time I ever smoked weed
was with that dude
in my car my little Ford Escort he was
like you got to try it it's medicinal
make you feel good he was telling me how
they don't believe in modern medicine
and then it was the first time also I
ever heard Bob Marley he played Bob
Marley for me I totally forgot about
that and then I dropped him off and that
was it it was totally safe and cool no
sexual enough nothing that when you were
14 going the truck stops what was the
scariest thing could happen to you with
a guy there mm-hmm
honestly nothing scared me I never
remember beings but I was so unaware and
I wasn't cute I was never cute until I
was like 25 so it wasn't like guys are
looking at me I looked like a boy
yeah limitation I can get people to pay
me $80 for leader suck their dick at the
truck stop you understand me
good-looking for looks little truck stop
good-looking for meth and a set of lips
that's it I was always there with a
couple other older kids okay no I was
never by myself no cuz I was 14 but I'm
running out with like kids that were 17
back then so they would drive and we
were
oh that really sick okay that makes a
big difference yeah thinking look I'm
seeing a young girl named 14 and 10 you
know in a world of you know what type of
guy that's a man could really look at a
fourteen-year-old it's gross to them
because I never look at a fourteen
[ __ ] even a planet that's disgust
living when you look at a young girl go
WOW especially back then when you could
really like really tell that they were
14 yes a little different now sometimes
I see guys that I think must be like 30
and they're like 21 like I can't tell
the difference anymore sometimes they're
really young you know like even girls
you can't tell anymore
they'll know how to do makeup and like
girls out here get like their boobs done
when they're 18 and I don't know it's
different now I think
plus they have sex younger I was talking
to some kid the other day he was like 15
is like I lost my virginity when I was
12
like it's crazy to me I was 19 how old
were you the first time you had sex
because it was crazy
I had different things like that you
would like yeah okay make out with I
don't even know what I did with fake
cousins what do you mean fake cuz it's
like your mom and another girl what the
high school together
I consider them social Society and then
you had kids they have kids so as you
guys were growing up you guys were
considered cousins yeah they prayed that
you married their son you know when you
were both for they would go oh my god
someday they're gonna be married but
that never happens that's hilarious
but sometimes in you at that age you
play house with your cousins so I
remember I had my mama's partner to the
drycleaners and then a girl named Evie
and she was really cute
and she was a little older than me and
that was the first time I ever saw with
a hairy [ __ ] like I didn't have a hair
as she did and on a Friday nights we
were allowed to watch TV till 8:00 the
living room and she was the first girl
like that
my toe like whoa look at this and she
showed it to me know your [ __ ] in them
you know the whole thing I was like I
had and I can't tell you what I did with
it I'd love to tell you that I [ __ ]
her I don't remember that because I was
such a calf like that yeah like it took
me a long time to accept a [ __ ] it
took me a long time to like even though
I'm so I always I remember even at very
young I was boy crazy and I was always
like I was always really horny always
but I was raised very christian-like
don't do it till you're married and so
even now as much of a freak as I am it's
still hard for me to just have a hook up
with like a random like it happens
occasionally if I'm like [ __ ] up
partying but even now as open-minded as
I am to like threesomes and I like to
[ __ ] alleys and like crazy [ __ ] but
I'm super picky still like I don't hook
up a ton although I totally forgot this
just happened this is crazy so you know
I was a virgin when I got married and
right after my marriage the first guy I
dated it was the only real boyfriend
I've had since we pretty much lived
together more or less for a year this
superhot like model type guy
I haven't we dated for about a year he
was too young he didn't really want a
relationship I thought he was cheating I
shouldn't have been in one I was still
getting divorced so it didn't work we
would fight a lot and back then I was so
much more jealous now I'm so chill back
then I would get pissed if he was like
out with a girl that he was friends with
anything so we broke up I haven't seen
him in four four and a half years or
something he showed up in LA the other
day I didn't know they was even here and
he messaged me like hey I'm in town we
should get a drink catch up so I went
now to drink with them it was so surreal
because first of all at the time he was
the first guy my sex with my ex I told
you before wasn't right like we
shouldn't have been really [ __ ] right
so this guy was the first I ever
really felt like I had hot sex with but
he was in some ways the first guy I ever
really like had any kind of crazy sex
with at all
like he was the first guy that I like
[ __ ] in a bar the first guy that like
he would pick me up when I would fly in
he would pick me up at LAX and like I
would literally be so hot - [ __ ] him by
the time I got to luggage I would be
like dripping literally dripping like
one time I remember I didn't have
underwear oh and I was like dripping and
I would make him eat my [ __ ] in the car
on the way home wait so I hadn't seen
him so now I see him it's so weird cuz I
don't feel any of that attraction he's
still hot but I didn't want him and we
hung out he ended up going back to my
place and just talking till like 4:00
a.m. about the whole thing and he kind
of was like I think you were the one and
I [ __ ] up and I was like I don't think
so
I don't I don't think it was right and
he was like I miss you and I was just
like well thanks I didn't know what to
say and then he started kissing me and I
didn't know what to do because he's
really sweet and nice but I wasn't
feeling it but I tried to go with it to
see if it would come back and I started
getting turned on but I didn't want to
[ __ ] him so I let him just go down on me
so so he starts going down on me and I'm
like wait just so you know I'm not gonna
[ __ ] you I'm not gonna touch your day so
if you don't you know if you're gonna be
too turned on you should stop he's like
that's cool so he goes down on me dude I
don't know what happened since we broke
up because I don't remember him eating
[ __ ] like that or maybe I wasn't as
sexual but oh my god it was like the
best I've ever had
it was so good I started reevaluating my
whole life and thinking in my head like
could I maybe date him again should I
move him to LA like it was that good and
he did it for so long so long like hours
and then he kept being like sure you
don't want to [ __ ] right and I was like
yeah no don't want to [ __ ] even though I
really really did but I I just felt like
since I said I wouldn't I had to stick
to it so I did it so
I finally kicked him out at like 5:00
a.m. I didn't even let him spend the
night because I was like if you stay
we're gonna [ __ ] you got to go and I had
to get up at like 8:00 so I kicked him
out so he left then the next night I ran
into my other ex who I also haven't
[ __ ] in a really really long time who
was the best sex of my life and I was so
horny from the night before from letting
og go down on me all night even though I
can't stand that's other ex when I saw
him everything in me was like you have
to [ __ ] him so I ended up going home
with him and I think it was the best sex
of my life I was telling you at the ice
house I've never had this before so yeah
hoji must be pissed if he hears the CD
me like I said like it so G oh my and
you bump into the Exley he next thing
you know he's banging in the [ __ ]
muffler I don't even but the problem is
he wasn't in the muffler Joey could the
problem is oh gee number one doesn't
live here and two og was like a real
relationship that like it was very hard
to get over like I really really had a
hard time this other X is one like the
girl you were talking about that like we
have hooked up on and off for like five
years like pretty much since that dude
but we can't date because he's crazy
jealous to the point of like if you like
my photo on Instagram he'll call me be
like you [ __ ] Joey Diaz now you
[ __ ] lee-sia like every guy so we
could never date cuz even if I'm with
him and I look at my phone he's like who
you texting who you fight so but the sex
I mean it's [ __ ] like it's so good
when I masturbate he's the only guy I
think about still after all these years
we [ __ ] on a trampoline I mean but
here's the thing that night it's never
happened to me before it was like he
didn't even have to touch me if we were
inches apart I could feel I could feel
him without him touching me chemistry's
real guy dude
people do not believe in chemistry I
know so real I had a dear friend for
years that I knew it I knew why we were
fine the chemistry the chemistry I knew
was just and we did it will fry this for
12 years yeah but did you ever hook up
oh yeah Wow
I dig busted be just once yeah that's it
that's all we needed
interesting chemistry was so strong
between us and you'll see that in life
you haven't meet women that you think we
guys that in the perfect package that's
happening they have a job yeah they're
responsible but no chemist son I ain't
saying that G and the opposite like I've
hooked up with guys you know some of the
guys I hooked up with aren't that
good-looking that but there's chemistry
like I said for some reason something
about you something about that something
something there's people who were
perfect for you but stepmother loves him
he's in law school
they're always he was a quarterback no
cab but you don't like this mother [ __ ]
is a sleeping pill I mean I've gone out
with guys that are so perfect that I've
tried to make them work and there's just
no chemistry but they're boring they're
vanilla am i blocking his camera no no
okay but then there's like the other
thing though is I've read and I kind of
am starting to believe this that if you
feel that with someone some theories are
that that means they're toxic for you
because they fill something in you that
you need on a base level which means you
need them to as much think about
something you could write this down if
you need to the people you've had the
best sex with the most toxic other
people you learn stocks always they take
the most energy from you we have to move
forward
yep you know they always visit this one
of the way in the private is Damon
that's only two weapon the old one years
ago he used to always Balkan crazy
[ __ ] always have the best person at
the time I was dating a crazy [ __ ] and
I had never experienced what I had
experienced with this woman people
always go with Joe Rogan always says you
got you I was really terrible when I
moved our but when I stopped date that
girl my commie blue oh my god because
she sucked the energy out
Madonna [ __ ] Guy Ritchie over guy rich
he's got no towel that because Madonna
sucked his dick so all the talent left
have you seen that movie with
the guy from the sun's I have a key it's
so bad that watch and every time it's on
HBO it's a joke guys
so want to keep walking in because I
love my point is that sometimes if
somebody was perfect for you they felt
every gap except the gap it's true okay
I haven't found it ever that someone the
sex is SuperDuper hot and also they're
actually good for me it's never happened
to me in my life ever but it's
interesting you said that what you just
said because I swear to God I said it to
Jessica my friend earlier today I said
since the last guy I dated and not just
him but right around the time stuff went
down and I stopped seeing that guy also
I cut I just cut a lot of people out
that I felt like we're kind of a little
toxic friends job absolutely anyone that
was dragging me down and tightened up my
circle right I swear to god Joey and
you've seen it I told you in the last
like three months everything is starting
to come together with my career and I'm
so much more creative productive like
I'm producing more [ __ ] I'm writing more
and I know that's why because I finally
just had this little tight circle of
awesome people and also I don't give a
[ __ ] even though I hooked up with the
dudes I don't care like I'm not trying
to date anybody I'm just trying to focus
on like my friends in my career and me
for the first time I've never in my life
put me first ever ever I've always put
like my friends first the guy first and
for once I'm being like yeah I don't
wanna do that I'm just gonna do what I
want stand-up comic which means you're
on stage by yourself with a microphone
yeah let me give some shoutouts real
quick
sherry Robeck Greg Reed doc Dominique o
Salas Razvi rostro cash Donovan Jennifer
Perez Pilate Valda Leticia Keeton and my
man up there in a true BJJ Matt
[ __ ] Baker up there in
Bakersfield
running things we had an extra show on
Thursday night in Salt Lake City yeah
eight o'clock show we had added
on Thursday night and don't forget
Kansas City
August 9th to the 11 to myself and beam
down [ __ ] rizk [ __ ] so it's
gonna be a hell of a [ __ ] gel I gotta
ask you something you said some very
interesting that I just want to see what
your take is on it I don't know if this
is a selfish thing or this is something
you need to do a there's an agent in the
business and I was friends with this guy
and I swear to God what there was
nothing I'm like I'm never gonna call
this [ __ ] again and here we are
seven years later you know he was a guy
that got me independent work and I paid
him 10% whenever he got me he was your
agent yeah he was like an age you know
and somebody came to me about a year ago
and said hey man I bumped into
what's-his-name he said you stopped
talking' tall are you mad then when I go
no no no something else happened then I
pulled him aside I go probably you ever
have somebody you have to stop talking
to because it's not getting anywhere
anymore
and he does that happen to me recently
is that something selfish that we do is
it correct to do like is this the way
you were raised we or it's it's you were
raised to do something like this it's
weird because it is different here I
think because like I went through
something recently super similar I had
to basically break up with one of my
best girlfriends because just over time
I realized that it was becoming that
relationship was becoming more work to
sustain than it was good for me and it
was more like I was putting as much
energy into that as I was into my career
and I think though everywhere else like
when I lived in Ohio
Chicago anyone you met was kind of an
acquaintance they were a friend everyone
was kind of there was no real big
difference because you didn't meet as
many people you didn't network it wasn't
this industry la is all about meeting as
many people as you can and learning what
they do and who they are and everyone's
like how can this person help me and
what can they do for me and so all the
relationships as much as you want them
to be just based on friendship there's
always a slant to all
most any relationship here so when I
first got out here I remember thinking I
swear to God I remember thinking man
everybody I know who's really successful
in this business is so [ __ ] selfish
all they care about is themselves they
don't do anything back for anybody else
and I used to think that was like an
[ __ ] quality but now that I'm getting
to a point where I'm getting super busy
it's so crazy you brought this up I've
been struggling with it I've been having
to really ask myself like what is it
worth to make it in this business
because it does get so busy especially
your past if at the point where I'm at
right now is like the top of the middle
like the hardest part of the grind I was
there yeah just I'm so big you're
featuring you headlining it's not even
that it's just it's just that I'm so
busy right now
but I'm I don't have quite the full team
yet to help you you're stuck in limbo
you're the limbo it's a weird yeah but
the thing is that only the people above
me like you know what that's like so my
friends and the people kind of on my
level or who haven't quite got there yet
just think I'm blowing them off I'm
being selfish so it's finally hit me
those people I thought were selfish were
just right here where I am now I'm here
so I get it but I didn't get it till I
was here like lately you can see it on
my social media I'm barely even posting
because I've been so [ __ ] busy I
can't even look at my phone and when I
do I got to answer 40 messages from like
work [ __ ] before I can get to writing a
joke or texting a friend back so of
course all my friends are gonna be like
she doesn't give a [ __ ] about me and she
doesn't answer me unless it's an
emergency
but it's not it's just I have to choose
do I want to make it or do I want to
have a million friends because at some
point I feel like you have to pick and
that's probably why it's loneliest at
the top because you lose people on the
way over over the last three years I
stopped talking to Tony people yeah that
I didn't have to stop talking to them I
had to move forward that's
it because do you actively not talk to
them or do you guys just drift apart is
there a difference it's a little bit of
boss
yeah doesn't one for me too there's a
little bit of both it's a little bit of
both and sometimes you know there's some
people drift if there weren't really
your friends as they drift that's just
the way life is
is it you and this town people show up
as your friends but they have mitigating
circumstance they want something from
you what's your move and you get to see
these people you get to be around them
you get to see them and when they don't
get what they want then you see how they
change camps and you see how quick it is
to get their respect any like wow
they're doing all this but the one thing
I could do is work that was really hard
for me though because like coming here
maybe because I'm from the Midwest or
the way I was brought up but like that
was really hard
that was a thing I had to learn last
year really was like I saw a lot of
people I kind of like let him go to see
what would happen if I couldn't give him
anything and I just saw so many people
flip and I was like wow it's just I
never I wasn't raised like this either
yeah I wasn't raised to be like this
either today yesterday a friend called
and we have you know she lives in San
Francisco she used to live here and she
she came here to be a manager but you
know what happens here and good lady you
know she tried to help me she was hard
she had no heart you know it wasn't what
she wanted to do and she moved on we
were still friends I know our husband
you know and she called me to say hello
and she was with somebody who one
morning I had to stop being this
person's right after 10 years there's a
comic that it just wasn't going anywhere
as a comic there every conversation was
negative and every conversation was
negative in my direction because I was
doing things she wasn't doing yeah you
know she was mad at me and to be honest
with you she was such a dear friend that
before this whole podcast thing star
she called me one that and she goes have
you heard about the podcast didn't fly
even that late and I go yeah but she
goes I like to do them would you like to
do them with me like I would love to do
a waitress crazy and I go one do you
know how to do it she looks long way my
friend taught me how the tape and I
could do it like okay when do you wanna
do it would you come down anymore like
okay I called her three days in a row I
go she never called me back like oh this
is the same person I've always known so
I did the podcast of Felicia like six
months later and then she kind of said
something to me one day that was kind of
weird like you left me in the lurch and
hey you know what you want to yell at
something you go I'm not even gonna
[ __ ] go there
yes and then me and Lee did something
and she lived around the corner and she
showed up at one of our events kind of
drunk and she started a fight with a gay
guy in the back room oh my god and
another time she showed up at my house
and caused controversy that's bad too
when someone's embarrassing you look bad
that too and this was going on for years
and I tolerated it because of our
friendship
but now that we're in this type of
League and all this stuff is going on
she called me one night and she was like
that I'm at The Comedy Store and they
won't let me in who these [ __ ] people
think they are and I go up can I ask you
a questions he goes why don't [ __ ] do
you think you well why would they just
let you win [ __ ] you I know you don't
even do comedy them she was yeah but I'm
down here to this I go listen that's not
the way it works I was at home I know
there's nothing I could do for you yeah
you're not even there cuz she like told
me off on the phone I go [ __ ] yourself
and then one morning I was having no
surgery no big deal I'm gonna at 9:00 in
the morning I'll be home by lunchtime
right like I hadn't heard from her in
like eight months and rent the phone
with all the surgery my phone blowing up
in surgery even the nurses do you want
to check what that is it could be an
emergency and it's her and she's like I
just write on Twitter you haven't
surgery I'll never forget this oh my god
why am I the last to know I go
because you never called me back to do
that [ __ ] podcast you [ __ ] dummy
I'm gonna do me a favor go [ __ ] yourself
you're gonna call me and make me feel
bad because she was like a fake friend
although she is so to make a long story
short like that was it
like that was the last time I spoke to
her and yet today yesterday her friend
called and she oh she's here with you do
you want to speak that I know why you
put me in this [ __ ] position and I
felt weird later on I go you know and
when you grow nothing bothers me more
than when people don't grow yeah nothing
bothers me more than when you befriend
somebody and you kind of colleagues with
them and then you grow and they don't
grow and they get mad at you because
they don't well right totally
also though like I I'm kind of like a
guy which is why a lot of my friends are
guys but in the way I communicate I am
NOT passive-aggressive ever like I say
what's wrong immediately cuz I just want
to fix it like if I had something with
you I would call you and that's the
other thing you [ __ ] talk on the
phone
anyone that won't pick up the phone and
[ __ ] talk to me at this point in my
life especially now I get why you're
like that cuz you probably get a billion
[ __ ] texts a day and you don't want
to read a paragraph and it takes so long
to text back it's so much easier to call
I can't tell you I've cut people out
just cuz they won't call me that's it if
you are texting me more than three
sentences you have to [ __ ] call me
cuz I don't have time so if they won't
call and they're being
passive-aggressive I don't know what's
wrong I used to let like try to figure
it out so I'm the middle child I would
be like why what's wrong what what did i
do why why are you talking to me now I'm
like alright I give up and I just cut it
off like everything it's making me
lonely Orcs I have less friends but it's
making me happier said better people
well that's the thing that's the that's
the decision you have to make you know I
still talk to my friends in childhood
yep I make it a habit yeah
sadly on George you know that's my
favorite when I yell at George because
he's coming out in it to do that [ __ ]
Comic Con oh that's cool
I hate torments me to go down that the
chances of getting me in San Diego you
got a better chance to me [ __ ] making
a new hangar myself it's the worst Drive
it's the worst you'd have to fly yeah
take the train oh it's coming I've never
been no I would love to go to that it's
kind of twofold because I didn't really
experience it too much before I started
doing stand-up because I would have
friends from work I have to my friends
out here to be honest but it is kind of
weird being in LA just because everyone
who comes out here it's a vacay it's
like the dream vacation for them so I
had a friend out here the last week who
Friday at 3 p.m. texted me come hang out
with us in Hermosa Beach and thankfully
I had a show to do so except no but they
just like they think that you're just
having fun all the time so you could
drop everything and go to Hermosa so
that's tough I haven't really had to
break up with a friend yet but it is
like I always now that I know I've heard
these stories about other comics I am a
little bit I do put up a little bit of a
wall at the open mics like yeah there's
not there's some people that I'm
friendly with but I also I I'm very
cautious around people now from here I
used to just [ __ ] talk I would just
[ __ ] talk I believed everybody not
throw shade just be open yeah the way I
talked to you I would just I would tell
the truth to everybody and share my
feelings and I forget if it was you
someone said to me oh I think it was
dice he said no one is your friend in
his town remember that until they prove
it and I was like that's that's a
terrible way to be but it's kind of
[ __ ] true because it's happened
before where I've shared too much with
someone and then found out later like
they weren't really a friend and now I'm
like [ __ ] I never should have told him
that story we don't know somebody's
something and they kind of like use
again chin you like that's the creepiest
thing I've ever heard
yeah I read these little people send me
[ __ ] a couple weeks ago something posted
a reddit thing a guy it was being Joey
Diaz we remember shred I'm ready that
was brilliant about that I rob people
with that no way
thank you someone goes into the Facebook
group for the podcast and it's like I
don't like Joey Diaz and even the people
in the group were like why are you here
well like they're so stupid even going
there in the first place cuz all your
fans are gonna just like destroy them
you don't even have to say anything guys
forget the fans forget all this [ __ ]
when you decide to get into a comedy
business way before I decide to get the
comedy business like I thought about it
I'm like people are not gonna like me
the same way I don't like such and such
like when I got into comedy i watch the
trauma calmly we all do
yeah we've all watched yeah putana
calmly and you since you've never done
it you're a fan of everybody's right
like since you haven't done it you're a
fan of everybody's but there's two or
three people that you don't really think
much of right okay that's natural that
she is a comic yes just like music like
certain songs well I haven't economy so
I decided right then and there
write them in there when I got on stage
in 91 that was not gonna like me that's
good that you did that I never even
thought about was I was bombing all
those years because I was in the Midwest
yeah doing [ __ ] jokes yeah this is not
better a [ __ ] action adventure
why no I never even thought about it
yeah I was in Denver I'm Midwest
I'm when I was a widow you know they
don't know I'm CUBAN don't give a [ __ ]
no stag I never I cut my teeth in
Wyoming and Montana and Ogden Utah and
oh you know so I was just like a big
[ __ ] we don't either you like me you
did so when I go
YouTube oh I hate reading the comments
and I read a comment and somebody
doesn't like me it doesn't bother me I
could look you in the face and tell you
that I'm already programmed because I
know as a as a human being that if we
all white vanilla it would be a boring
[ __ ] world if we all liked Florida it
would be a boring [ __ ] world that's
why I like outspoken people you know
what I really don't like my Vegas I'll
look at them and go why not tell me your
reason it I'll know if that person's
faking the funk yeah like I'm at one
time being at that diner 101 I love that
place I love that place too coconut milk
shake for breakfast [ __ ] delicious
I'm gonna go in there late night and eat
aren't they open late yeah till like
three or four three before yeah but I
didn't like one night having a
conversation with a waitress there she
goes if you have a left ear where would
you got my phone I'm gonna be old
someday maybe I'll go to Tahoe Vegas and
get like a residency and right away she
started with that Silver Lake lingo that
self corporate environment of capitalism
how can you even want to be an artistic
how can you have artistic freedom
working in Las Vegas in a capitalist you
know those people I guess I don't want
to be around those [ __ ] being that's
true those are the people I yeah me
neither
give me a reason you know what
everything on Vegas I see
I feel disparity in the air I do I do I
feel I do it a lot I feel the money need
I feel the need for friendship I need
people really go to Vegas really think
they gonna fall in love that does happen
I feel in Vegas I feel so bad I like
going into the cheap casinos in Vegas
where you can still smoke in the whole
casino but like the ventilations not
that good like the the old ones and you
don't even have to go to old Vegas like
even on the strip there are still a few
and it's so different cuz you can tell
looking at the clientele and those ones
those are the people that are there they
either need to make money it's a more
desperate
tell it's not the tourists that are on
vacation but that is like the best
people-watching because those are the
people you're talking about that are
like either old guys trying to just make
enough to buy some hot girls at drinks
they can maybe get [ __ ] or a little
take a little money to the strip club or
old ladies with white hair playing like
penny slots like I love watching that
see that's the one that I don't like is
the older women at the slot it makes me
feel sad like they're spending all their
money Lee but I do like there's always
the time that you brought me to the UFC
like I stayed an extra I went to like a
really seedy casino it's just that
that's why I fell in love with blackjack
not even like the winning but just the
camaraderie at the table like these
older guys were like and my mom had this
hang that every gambler almost won like
sweet it whenever it's not hear someone
saying stuff like that I think of her
but he had a story like they wouldn't
let me make a bet and I would have won
10,000 and he was going off and telling
the story and and yelling at the dealer
but he [ __ ] him last night but like in
a funny way like it's yeah everyone has
a sad story of like how they almost made
10 grand dude the first time I ever I
was old the first time I ever actually
gambled in Vegas cuz I was always like
afraid because I'm so addictive I was
scared to bet and I walked in a casino
with some somebody I can't remember who
it was a friend a guy we walked up to a
war table you know that gave you a are
war he put down a hundred bucks okay
goes waa our war whatever we won so 100
bucks just like that I was like oh [ __ ]
this is easy so I immediately thought
everybody just wins in Vegas so the
whole rest of the week I tried to make
money and I just lost I think I lost
like a thousand bucks or something like
that which at the time was a lot I was
like 25 I never gambled in Vegas since
then I don't gamble when I go there so
I'm so scared that I'll get hooked and
lose all my money so if you see me
gamble it's with someone it's because
like I sat at a table on some dude
handed me money like then I'll play but
I'm not playing with my money ever but I
have 120 dollars a few times with other
people's money
but how are often are you in Vegas and
that old dude just hands you $500 if
you're a girl and you stand at a table
where a bunch of guys are playing long
enough someone is giving you money to
play definitely it's [ __ ] crazy but
not a lot I mean guys will just buy you
in and give you a few chips it's never
happened to me like in the movies but
I'm also usually dressed in like flannel
and a hex I just did a show or something
I'm never like in a hot dress maybe
you'd be different that'd be a good
experiment I don't know and I never go
to the baller tables whatever there's
like hi why wouldn't that be the place
to do it there I have so many empty
seats because I'm always when I'm in
Vegas I'm always working so it's always
I'm always in like comedy cause never
like more when I go to the fights I
dress up I love that you work a lot okay
I really lately I'm like non-stop it's
good good for you man and it shows it
shows I see it I see people talking you
can are they there you post a picture
you with those little baseball titties
well that's with some other chick I
looked at him I'm like the [ __ ]
implants gonna collapse top or the pool
the pool boy I don't know what the [ __ ]
it was you in a bikini the black bikini
is above that yeah it was beautiful
thank you mama she's busting the [ __ ]
through the time but you always do Ltd's
it's weird cuz I try to post less sexy
photos now than I used to just cuz like
I um I want to be more seen for comedy
but every once in a while I'm like [ __ ]
you oh [ __ ] what I'm gonna be I'm gonna
be old soon you know why not [ __ ] yeah I
still got I say one day I'm gonna look
back and go god damn I wish I could wear
that which I still will I won't show you
[ __ ] yet I never gonna show I've never
done topless even oh you do topless at
this stage what the [ __ ] [ __ ] for the
last week that's the last card right
there I'm gonna wait Psalm 82 show what
the Harvey Weinstein that's the end now
you're always working man your hospital
yeah every night you do Brian mono I
mean you do [ __ ] everything you know
and like I totally you know I respect
that lassie Dean I know who's faking the
funk you know and I was staying home you
see it yeah and I know who complains
and then I'll do the work and I see you
know that that I came home and told my
wife that time I know you know I just
bumped into Kate she just did the
weekend in Connecticut and she took a
6:00 a.m. flight with me she didn't
sleep here that I she's got a home sleep
and doing my charity spot at the store
on Sunday that I gone I asked I go why
he doing that she knows you can't pass
up a spot to start like oh that's why I
like Kate oh thank you that will stay
panel right there when you know you
can't pass up a spot at the store but
then this is every time that the time is
for sets they're scheduled up
I watched the retweets and I see [ __ ]
oh here we go again
it's macho night at the Comedy Store
just these angered Woman comics [ __ ]
bitching about the lineup at the store
and you never and you're not even a
regular at the store and you get 20
spots in there a week and [ __ ] that's
just the way life is
yeah so I give [ __ ] people respect who
deserve respect it's that easy like I'm
second [ __ ] die and I have been sick
and [ __ ] tired like my phone stopped
ringing in 2007 the misery calls those I
used to call those misery cause you know
after I did The Longest Yard for two or
three years and spider-man yeah I would
get misery calls from comics I read that
no I need to do you know did Joe Rogan
call Adam Sandler just add on this [ __ ]
I never know what to say when people ask
me what they need to do cuz I don't
really know I just worked that's it
that's it Wow I never but people ask
well what do I do
I don't [ __ ] know that's how I lost a
lot of those friends would be like well
your thoughts how do i how did you get
those spots you know what I used to do
to get [ __ ] spots when I first
started I swear to god this the truth on
Facebook everybody posts flyers for
every [ __ ] show in town anything a bar a
coffee shop whatever it is right every
flyer I would see I would look at who
produced it or as hosting it
no matter
where it was and I would add that person
as a friend and I messaged him every
couple weeks and just go hey if you ever
have a spot if you ever have a spot and
I would get up any [ __ ] spot in town I
could and that's how but the other thing
is I was just nice and I never asked for
[ __ ] I never asked you to do this
podcast ever I never asked anyone for
anything I just [ __ ] be nice and wait
that's it
but I think a lot of people like they
just they don't want to do the shows
that no one's listening the biggest
mistake you making my world disaster
this podcast okay yeah I know I know
have you just telling me you just
telling me that to put your [ __ ] I
want to see something yeah I gotta see
you doing some on social media I gotta
see you don't sign to learn yep
if I don't know you how can I put you on
this [ __ ] podcast well we have talked
about yeah like it's different if it's
someone I've had that they want to
promote yeah but even promote I mean
guys go on the [ __ ] radio oh yeah
totally
you know I don't mind people tell them
people dates I do it all the time buy
all that [ __ ] like when people hit us up
and I'll tell you even in the sponsor
department I was getting hit up to do
movies and maybe bring like the third
actor on the list to the show yeah and I
thought about I told that company now
not for what they wanted to pay us and
what we were gonna do I was gonna
compromise the audience exactly you
can't I don't know these people
yeah nothing about these people for this
with a little bit of change I was gonna
make I was no lie to my audience about a
movie that's always [ __ ] guy that I
don't know these beat yeah that's how I
am with ads on my Instagram what people
like hold our shake take it I'm like
[ __ ] that if I send it to me if I like
it I'll think about it
yeah people think like it's I can't wait
to get like Amelia Amelia is going to
podcast a thousand times
he's gonna be on my ins he's the one who
leads on mines that starts on FX or
sometime before I'm gonna have him on
you know John brought Bernard so I hope
to get him on in August you know these
are guys that they listen I know them
for you know I know I just don't want to
bother the mother wife bothers me you
know it's a good example is like I
haven't done Rogen and like every week
maybe five or six people will tweet
about it and I never even I would never
in a million years like reply back oh
yeah I wish or even like it or ask
people retweet that stuff I feel like
it's Joe show if he wants me to ask me
why the [ __ ] would I bother him then
he'll walk in the store when they into
the original winter Maine and you're on
a stage gentlemen yeah and you say
something that makes them laugh and
that's it you got I know no I know John
for 20 years yeah I know exactly how his
mind works and Joe is like so good to me
and always gives me good advice and like
he's great
I actually think Joe is so sweet I think
he's so great but like that's what I'm
talking about though like I can't
imagine when people ask me even I'm like
what why you it's it's so awkward
because they put you on the spot and
then what are you supposed to say only
podcast do you have that well date fails
at the pocket I love you Dave fail yeah
the date field school but the one I'm so
stoked about having you on is the
Hollywood pool party which so I used to
do it as live stream one day ever 10:30
in Hollywood and I'm waiting to hear
back to see if this lady could she wants
to see me have one in the valley but
mercy doesn't go to school till 4:00
just let me know I would have to blow up
I asked my wife my wife would wait 10:30
in Hollywood and then one in the valley
maybe you could come do it in between so
my buzz something like that dude it's so
10 days a pitch so I don't know yeah so
I don't know what its gonna [ __ ]
entail yeah this all came about we can
play my ears you're special but mercy I
want you to tape it so I can't see her
yeah so my wife just bought a [ __ ]
thing she went to big watts and the lady
goes you know we have a sale for her can
I have an extra coupon the manufacturer
there's my wife those they're a lot yeah
some type goes with $79 this was perfect
Joey and it comes them blower it's a
pool it's a [ __ ] a slide is it an
inflatable pool with the slide
oh my
I have one there's a basketball court
yours has a bastions a basketball court
so you [ __ ] we got it in the backyard
I'm so excited with the sprinkler that
comes out so you stand on the side with
the microphone and if it's really hot
the sprinkler hit show Joey spends all
day in this food I have booms in the
pool I went out there the other day with
her she was out there was a Konya
degrees in the back you shot we did it
we had a [ __ ] blast her and I my wife
put the whole [ __ ] thing together my
wife is back there putting [ __ ]
things at stake stress so excited I'm so
you have to do it at your place yes I
said to you cuz first you have to do it
with you and let her be the star you
can't curse no I shall do the bikini
weekend the whole [ __ ] deal oh my
girl on there to give you some flavor
this is literally it's like my favorite
show I brought you guys over the other
night I did that's ariza she knew it
like I said I said she goes daddy have
to work yeah and she goes are you gonna
come back earlier do you want me to
sleep in your bed and watch the bed for
you
macaroni she goes so are you gonna have
your friends with you or like no Lisl
view of me and she goes the ones you
bring me back and watch you have a party
yes I can't we just haven't half the
party yeah let's have it half the part
no I said what are you guys talking
about like why I would have too far like
at 10:30 and my wife is telling well I
see it would be smooth dough might know
she's done well she'll wind up first
round without the party and mercy sex
leads come on we have to get beats I
know least company and so is Kate
Quigley you never met Kate she's
probably gonna show up with a bikini I
had a role and my wife is just shaking
her head so we walked in there at 10
o'clock at night the air core wide
manually half asleep she's asleep
the baby's [ __ ] strain happen I'm
telling a Huey Dewey and Louie will
watch him here we do in Louie had told
us that cousin Stewie's doing 10 years
for [ __ ] bond embezzlement and she got
pissed off at me like don't say that to
me about Stewie there's no Stewie she
was also
pajamas more like gonna make us some
cocktails or something like you brought
up cocktails she's just like let it fly
she responds yeah yeah
does it respond to you she knows I'm
breaking the ball she's so funny and
then she was mad they put the wrong name
on her on her doll she made it's cool is
that they wrote Hannah my name is mercy
not Hannah she's look she is so cute
she's so sweet though she's like you
when you're not podcasting or doing
comedy she's got you're like ho you know
what I love about you I [ __ ] this is
I swear to God when I saw you at the
airport in New York at JFK we're on that
same flight every time I see you from a
hundred hundred yards away you have the
most [ __ ] eating grin on your face
always always you always have a big-ass
smile and that's what it is about you
like you tell dirty jokes but you're
just [ __ ] like you just exude light
like warm like you're just so warm what
is it that at the end of the day though
are we really really angry about yeah
when you really really think about it
we're so lucky all the anger I carry
them in my twenties which some of it was
due to life I still had anger in me my
thirty still in anger me in my forties
and in my 50s I still have this anger in
me and just recently I woke up one day I
know you know what listen here it is
plain and simple I work eight times a
[ __ ] month and I leave my house six
days a month and I make a living have a
good life and I get to go to my
daughter's rats I'm not missing meals
but I'm not getting rich either
I'm not boo CK or Kevin Hart and guess
what guys I don't want to me you need me
I wouldn't worry I'm very happy you know
I'm very happy coming over here with me
you know he's employed this is this is a
dream yeah true when I eat when I used
to go to the open mics with me and I'd
sit there I'd look at these guys might
know this was me 25 [ __ ] years ago
sitting there dreaming about forming at
the Comedy Store The Improv the laughs
factory's gettin flown in yeah you know
I didn't have any there was no TV
there was nothing people like well you
know listen all that was there was be
[ __ ] funny I didn't give up my family
rooms I think they don't [ __ ] about
headshots on your phone where I know at
the end of a [ __ ] week if you
couldn't do the job on that stage this
whole thing is in vain if you're gonna
be smaller errors is this face to be a
[ __ ] oil commercial years ago and the
model for them what are you gonna do pay
me the hell would you pay me later
that's never left me that means you're
gonna do it work now but you can do the
work man it's up to you but you're gonna
do the [ __ ] work you have so roll up
your [ __ ] sleeves take the bad look
off your face yo and prepare a [ __ ] for
10 [ __ ] years before you see anything
I've been here 12 years yeah for 10
[ __ ] years before you see anything
who the [ __ ] are you who owes you
anything you [ __ ] sack of [ __ ]
prepare to be in ten years so anybody
who says are lowly
it's [ __ ] ten years and then maybe
maybe if you're [ __ ] lucky someday
[ __ ] them talk to you it's true it's
[ __ ] true this is it you know your
date brother sat in that chair and I've
been thinking about the statement I made
and you know what's [ __ ] crazy that
you really think about it you're like
you know what I'm going to the [ __ ]
laughs one day that yeah
being a six year comment Cynthia Thomas
but the last three committed like I
don't know what you're talking right
Alex what's Netflix [ __ ]
I know cocaine and Tommy yeah and how to
drive a [ __ ] car the next game
that's all I [ __ ] know what I went to
an open mind I went to a Latino night at
the [ __ ] Laugh Factory
I saw kid by the name of Johnny Sanchez
go out there oh I love Johnny and do a
joke about no parking him by parking out
whenever you see Arabs and [ __ ] in
Europe they jumping up and down and that
at the end of the [ __ ] week it's the
same cousin for a guy in Glendale and
then [ __ ] I forget it was--what up
somebody else went up them that was
brilliant at the time but then Pablo
Francisco went up and libeled the room
yeah he was doing voices and he did the
whole cast of Seinfeld huh in Spanish
and guys i sat there that was like oh my
god I'm moving back to Seattle
I'm not coming down I'm not ready for
this listen there's a thousand people
Kate and you have to think about this
there's a thousand people rather sad
reality they're a lot more talent than
you there are a lot more talent than me
and leaner alum what the hell they do
I'm sorry to break that news to have any
cream all three you guys including
myself just people [ __ ] really
talented out there yeah but you want me
to tell what the real talent is fix
again that's so true that's the sound
I've seen it I won't live that I've been
here you could tell me every story you
[ __ ] want yeah I've seen you know
I've seen it all
I've seen it all you know I also saw
Dave grow be a drummer on Nirvana and
now he's one of the greatest performers
in the world on Foo Fighters Nathan he
sat there and played it out yeah he did
this time this is all about time the
talent isn't that you are a [ __ ]
prodigy although he's a 21 year old
bronzy look at him on stage [ __ ] it
takes a lot more than being a prize
[ __ ] comedy spot to nest so just
remember that that talent is not playing
the piano and sang it a jumbled up in
that
and yeah you're gonna have talent I'm
some people [ __ ] phenomenal on [ __ ]
Twitter and Facebook and social me
they're gonna get two hundred million
views but the talent is us continually
driving
so whatever comedy club to do that
midnight spot
well you gotta love it you got a lot of
it because even if you get Kevin Hart
huge at some point Kevin Hart's slope
starts to go like this and then it may
come back like this and like I mean it's
always up and down no matter how famous
you get this business so if you don't
love it like that story I told on here
about Chappelle wouldn't go to the store
on a Monday night at 1:00 a.m. if you
don't love it enough for that then why
are you doing it cuz the fame the money
like the level of Fame that you're at
people know you cuz they're a fan they
like what you do they don't know you
stay read about you in a tabloid they
saw a photo of you out with Kim
Kardashian they know you cuz they like
you I'm sorry like my gig gig is not a
lot of parties my gig is not to hang out
with nobody I don't want nobody nothin
like that my gig has always been -
you're a comic I never told nobody ever
director Lisa I yeah seven years you've
been around me ever hear the word
producer come out of my mouth
not really I'm a [ __ ] dirty comic
[ __ ] no better than you [ __ ]
number the day I went on I went on an
audition a few weeks ago and I called
Joey the minute I got out do you
remember I called you and I said this
was the worst [ __ ] [ __ ] audition
that had to go in there and the premise
of the show is they play a comedians bit
and then they have another comedian act
out the bit but I had to lip-sync the
bit like I had to [ __ ] they played
the jokes on tape and I had to lip-sync
it like I was lip-synching a song but I
didn't know that's what it was gonna be
so halfway through I stopped it and went
wait a second I'm lip-syncing her jokes
people know I'm a comic and they were
like right and I was like yeah I'm not
doing this and I just left and I called
Joey and was like listen to this and he
was like [ __ ] that [ __ ]
we're comics we don't [ __ ] audition
for that [ __ ] the comics that was to
me I was like that's why I [ __ ] love
Joey because you just
those rules well why would I do that is
the dumbest [ __ ] I've ever heard
lip-sync someone else's jokes is
[ __ ] it's not even acting you're not
even reading the lines you were
lip-synching this is the dumbest [ __ ] I
wish I could save the show but I want
[ __ ] that the problem is we forget in
the middle of everything with the
parties the tabloids of the e TV
sometimes we forget that we're just
dirty comics and would just here to
replace somebody and that's all that's
simply self-importance we have over 30
humming but you know what's nuts is
lately I'm so passionate about work not
just like not just listen like the pool
party show is my favorite like I [ __ ]
love doing it's dumb but it's fun it's
funny like people tell funny Hollywood
stories and blast in the last week I
think I did like ten spots two of my
podcasts like three of other people's
I'm trying to sell the show so I had a
few meetings and I did five episodes of
the pool party or whatever I was
literally not sleeping I mean I was
sleeping how long is the pool boys 10
minutes we film for 25 we cut it down to
like 15 yeah a short question yes
perfect it's perfect and it's all the
point of it is to break the illusion
that Hollywood is glamorous so the whole
point is like you take like a job you
book like The Longest Yard but then you
think of like those moments on that that
were like awful or like a terrible
audition that you thought was gonna be
amazing and it turned out to be like a
[ __ ] shot like the guy jerked off in the
casting remember like just [ __ ] like
that that breaks the illusion that
Hollywood is like we're all so it's all
Fame and makeup and red carpets and
you're like no [ __ ] like two bucks that
way next to the Oscars is like tent city
where like guys are pissing on each
other in the middle of the night you
know so but my point is I wasn't
sleeping I've never been busier but I
love everything I'm doing right now so
much that like I went to a party the
other night one night and it was a big
Hollywood party like John Mayer was
there like all these celebrities were
there I swear to god Joey I walked into
this party
I was there for like half an hour I was
like why am I here I could be editing
this
in pool show right now I don't give a
[ __ ] about this [ __ ] I'm leaving and I
just called an uber and left and that
was the first time I ever was like all I
really care about right now is what I'm
making I really don't give a [ __ ] about
who doesn't like me who talk [ __ ] who
anything else right now nothing else so
happy the reason why yeah yours is just
to do it die that's it we have forgotten
this as American as we forget this us is
not the reason when you ask some
questions all you gotta do is keep
showing up show up and do what makes you
happy
what's coming up for you would be
cheetah oh thanks for asking
uh well Tuesday night I promised Sam
Tuesday night I'm at the Comedy Store
for comedy chaos s-sick lineup but I'm
going to Connecticut not this weekend
next weekend so it's the 19th through
the 21st Mohegan Sun comics yes comics
you've done that place is gonna see you
really yeah oh yeah the one that wants
to have a threesome with me yeah ah [ __ ]
well maybe send me photos tweet me
photos I'm due for some sex you know
other than my ex is I hadn't [ __ ] in
like two months so and then anyway I got
August 1st through the 5th Minnesota and
then I got Sunnyvale roosters have you
played that joint ever let me know how
it is yes yeah it was really popular
when I moved here really and they went
through different ownership so I don't
know what's really going on up there
anymore it's like that too while we're
driving right for our drive I think it's
more I think it's like far I'm gonna fly
really really cool they would Sunnyvale
I've heard it's dope I've never done it
was an Olaf roster for a while they were
just doing clean Carly
they've gone so yeah they've got do so
many different things over the year I
really don't know what's up I heard it I
heard it's good from a few people we'll
see but I'm excited just because I
haven't headlined that area yet like San
Jose area so that hopefully we'll go to
Cleveland together we you know you're
accurate that would be done we do allow
these a [ __ ] 4th Street I would
take Quigley's homecoming his [ __ ] and I
gotta just plug the photo shoot with
Holly Randall because we're trying to
get that's the one we're talking about
right
you put up and yet you look dead easy oh
no we haven't shot it yet the one that
we're doing the Kickstarter for so
Holly's like a legend in like adult
world but I won't be nude but Holly's
like one of the only female directors
and photographers who shop for Playboy
and stuff and she wants to shoot me but
she has this idea to do like a sexy
clown like a clown that's like really
like kind of gothic and sexy whatever so
we're trying to raise money for it and
then we're gonna do like really cool
implied nudes so nothing where I'll be
naked but I'll have like my boobs
covered but I won't be wearing clothes
okay y-you told me to do it
nothing naked no you can't advocate that
[ __ ] but they're gonna be like artsy
like you're hanging them you don't like
playboy go let's go thank you're gonna
show that [ __ ] show me that clip I
can't dress well Joey Jesus Christ the
clown thing is gonna be like Harley
Quinn with like black and white it's
gonna be good I want to see you an
apology was an apology yes they do I
don't want to say that but we're gonna
let people come watch I don't want to
come hang out come on set and come watch
you thinking no come watch the photo
shoot
notice if you're making people want to
come if you got clothes on well the
implied nude part there will be I will
be naked how do I apply that you do I'm
gonna be totally naked but I won't show
my [ __ ] or nipples so it'll be like
those side angle shots where it's like
there's not clothes but you're naked
dude I'm saying like pregnant women take
to showcase their bellies and the clown
run is gonna be cool cuz I'm a comedian
but they're sexy it's supposed to be
like a comedy hot photo this I took two
expired [ __ ] [ __ ] what's the [ __ ]
you drank candy sure you know what just
tell the people to support it Jesus
Christ we only need to raise a little
money and they get to come watch if they
live in the area really yeah so you let
me become watch they have to turn in
their phone at the [ __ ] door and yeah
that's the height of a background check
no we're not security
I'm not security well he'd be taking
pictures of put the little nipples on
and some guy runs up takes as it takes
our louis ck's on it shoots a little
long as he's standing far enough away
where it won't
me I don't really don't give a [ __ ] I'm
very chill right that's what he said you
wanted to be homeless for a summer you
came in like I don't want to try that
Wow this is why I love you I guess you
got a sense of humor you take everything
for what it is and the more I see the
more you [ __ ] grow last week when I
was on Rogan I was talking about this
thing I go that the people at grade over
there on us
cryotherapy I want to go there it's in
u.s. Carla therapies in Ventura
Boulevard I was talking about a thing of
the app called Lobethal and I took the
thing for Rogan and I checked it out
this [ __ ] thing does a lot man it
decreases inflammation and improves
lymph draining and improve blood
circulation increases energy promote
cellular rejuvenation reduce obesity as
part of a diet and exercise program and
for performance and recovery improved
muscle strength reduced post exercise
soreness decrease this is this is
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] so if you live in the
area here by myself or bird or any of us
or even the Hollywood area I think this
is the only place they have this Norbit
or bed and it's us crowd terapy in
Studio City call up did you get hot or
anything line down warm it you sleep
like a baby at night it's [ __ ] true
man you gotta take me there sometime
I've always loved I love all that [ __ ]
you know me I've never done either the
cryo thing if you go to us crowd therapy
tell them I sent you from the podcast to
church they'll probably give you a
couple dollars off I think if you only
the first time one time say 26 but
that's not the head no I'm gonna try it
just to test yourself yeah just to
really [ __ ] get your head too
so you're going out with your plugs line
you're going there with gloves on
underwear they give you socks what about
your eyes that's gonna be crazy your
eyes are fine okay you get your favorite
[ __ ] song- - how long you in there
three minutes and thirty Jesus Christ
how cold is it do you know how 50
degrees he's just surf in the winter and
that [ __ ] water hit your face oh [ __ ]
you go in there that starts music comes
on loud I put Madonna burn it up
I'll put me down a physical attraction
when it makes me dance this shirt I hope
punches anyway listen the podcast is
brought to you by my favorite on it they
got a product called alpha brain which
gets you [ __ ] sharper than a
[ __ ] and it's their flagship if
you don't like the product they give you
your money back and they don't want the
product like that's how much they
believe in alpha brain this is I'm
talking about on it and it does not [ __ ]
around I've been messing around without
after nine years I've known armory for
years Rogen's turned me on for some of
that products I gonna do Jitsu I drop a
little shroom type sports right do I not
do that [ __ ] you did two things with
you guys yeah you don't you never sit
down like in between rounds no I don't
say that that's that's the character
that's the character you don't sit down
you breathe it out and you walk around
and you maintain and you breathe and you
think about clarity you think because
that's what beliefs taught us when she
came on the podcast that breathing
clears your mind you know it's there's
so many things that you learn from
breathing but that's not what we're
talking about good get the [ __ ]
shroom tech go to Anna calm right now
press in church BAM and get 10% off your
order
number two you want Aggie you want
[ __ ] shin guards you want boxing
gloves you want when you go to Muay Thai
class you want the best you gotta deal
with Fuji how do I know cuz I live Fuji
I breathe Fuji peggy's in my world tip
top Magoo people geez people give me
other geese from other companies they're
nice guys but nothing serves the purpose
like a Fuji ge that [ __ ] super Ito
that Sakai point to even just the
all-purpose B that's ninety six dollars
right inline dollars listen nona Fuji
sports.com right now you're looking for
a tough gear you're a big guy you get an
a5 or an a6 from Fuji they also have
rash guards do yourself a favor go to
Fuji Sports calm right now press ENTER
CH ban get 10% off the Liberty house
plus the how about the podcast alright I
want to thank my queen the queen of the
church quite quickly
I Love You Man it's funny I could talk
to you forever I'll be - I like you're
one of my all-time favorite animals and
the people like you I just don't want to
put you on every other week cause people
get pissed off but I wouldn't have
anything to say you're always welcome
here thank you for your stories
you [ __ ] will add an extra show
in Utah so we got a Thursday night show
bring the [ __ ] bombs and then me and
Dean da whizzy all rolled into KC MO at
the improv Thursday Friday Saturday
October 9th no October August 9th 10th
and 11th are you [ __ ] kidding me or
what
anyway I love you guys thank you very
much for watching the show thank you for
listening thank you for supporting
thanks Scott Cunningham for running the
Facebook page and everybody on there
that shows love listen we're [ __ ]
family I'm with you you're with me and
they want to be well that's going to
tank cake quickly and I want to take my
main man that [ __ ] for always
making it happen to have a great weekend
and I'll see you [ __ ] Monday
morning tip top Magoo ready to rock
let's do this [ __ ] Lee and the weak
[ __ ]
let's do this [ __ ] Lee what do you got